Bond gets a Bridesmaids-style make-over, with
a touch of Miss Congeniality thrown in for
good measure, in writer-director Paul Feig's
new movie, Spy.
But don't go thinking that Spy is just a spoof
of Bond movies; there's no winking at the
camera here; instead the humour's played straight-faced,
and Spy works as a proper action-comedy.
The movie kicks off with a Bond-esque pre-credits
sequence followed by its own spin on a 007-style
song and titles.
Yet, in a don't-judge-a-book-by-its-cover
twist, the hero of Spy's story isn't a James
Bond, Jason Bourne, or Jack Bauer type.
It's Susan Cooper, a deskbound analyst whose
entire CIA career so far has been spent in
a vermin-infested basement office.
Of course, that changes and in true undercover
agent style, Spy takes us location hopping
around various European cities including Paris,
Rome, and Budapest.
Melissa McCarthy really gets to shine in her
third film with Bridesmaids and The Heat director
Paul Feig.
She does a great job in the lead, playing
what feels like a more multi-faceted character
than she has before.
The role of Susan Cooper gives McCarthy the
opportunity to bring to life a sweet-natured,
considerate and extremely competent character,
but also gives her the chance to explore a
side to that character that's bawdier, more
bolshie and, most importantly, more badass.
If gross-out gags are your bag, then there's
definitely something in Spy for you.
But, if like me, you could live without that
type of comedy, don't be put off as there's
much more to the movie than that.
As we've seen before, McCarthy's at home with
both dialogue-driven comedy and more physical
and visual slapstick humour.
For example, she has a lot of fun with her
various spy gadgets and aliases.
But what really makes Spy stand out, and provides
some of the movie's biggest laugh-out-loud
moments, is the superb support and interaction
McCarthy has with her co-stars.
As McCarthy's in-the-field partner, Jude Law
gets to do a brilliant back-door audition
for the role of James Bond, kind of in the
vein of Roger Moore.
Law's super-spy Bradley Fine has all the right
moves, the charm and unrivalled levels of
self-absorption.
Jason Statham may be best known for his tough
guy turns in movie franchises like The Expendables
and Transporter, but in Spy he gets the chance
to show his comedy chops by sending up his
usual action movie persona to hilarious effect,
and there's a fabulously knowing joke about
a particular Nic Cage movie!
Statham's character, a hard-nut CIA agent
called Rick Ford, comes across as the kind
of guy who's watched all of Statham's action
movies and confused them with reality.
Yes, Ford's so tough that when he touches
his stubbled chin, you can actually hear a
loud bristling noise!
However, his main skill lies in an unparalleled
ability to talk up his supposedly many and
varied utterly incredible exploits.
His totally preposterous anecdotes are funny
enough in themselves – I particularly liked
the ones about the Cirque de Soleil and poisons
–, but what really makes them side-splittingly
hysterical is the way he recounts them, completely
deadpan, with one outrageous detail or story
piled on top of another.
Rose Byrne puts in a great performance as
the movie's super-snobby baddie Rayna, who
never has a hair out of place or a make-up
malfunction and loves nothing more than looking
down her nose at, well, everyone.
I love West Wing star Allison Janney in pretty
much anything.
Here, she plays McCarthy's CIA boss in Spy,
and her reaction after watching an old video
of McCarthy at a CIA training camp is priceless.
As McCarthy's best CIA bud, Miranda Hart makes
a great, goofy, gawky addition to the cast.
Even though his character seems to be a walking,
talking stereotype, Peter Serafinowicz is
very funny as an extremely handsy Italian
agent.
Oh, and there's a couple of cameos in the
movie too – one of them is a lot more obvious
than the other!
On top of its good dose of comedy, Spy has
a number of decent and some very good action
scenes, including some hand-to-hand combat
that reminded me of Jason Bourne's fight with
hitman Desh in The Bourne Ultimatum, although
Spy's version is in a rather different setting.
Ok, so the plot gets a bit convoluted but
then so do the plots of many traditional spy
movies.
So, to sum up: Spy delivers just what you
want from a comedy: lots of big belly laughs
and great performances.
Spy gets 4 out of 5 Flicks.
Now, what do you think of Spy?
And what are your favourite action-comedies?
Oh, are you looking forward to Spy director
Paul Feig's Ghostbusters movie?
Let me know in the comments below!
My next video should be on Jurassic World,
so look out for that!
And if you like this video, do please share
it, hit the thumbs-up button & subscribe for
my movie reviews and interviews!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!